thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another Splendid episode
of the careful boys today we have with
us Christian Farina
[Applause]
anybody got any uh good road rage
stories Nick oh dude no not really
honestly I think all my road rage
stories are pretty uneventful I'm really
I've been really trying to work on it
and try not to curse and like not to
give reactions because I think it is
kind of [__] made to be like you're
gonna let that make you so angry because
I get so yeah I agree um but it is kind
of like
fun not fun cathartic I guess is the
word to release something you like it
it's a reflex yeah yeah it's a reflex
because you do feel like you're about to
like die sometimes but no I've never uh
really had any stories where like
I've flipped out on somebody and then
like a fight ensues I've like I've
gotten mad at people I don't know I
think that's crazy that's nuts that's
wild on the way home today I get in the
fight with somebody and I'm like oh I
wish I had the story for OTR uh no but
there's been times where as soon as some
guy will almost hit me
I'll be flipping out I'll be yelling on
my car screaming or whatever and then
I'll drive by them and they just go
sorry
I'll just go like call I I hate that I
feel so bad I'll be like it's worse when
they flip you off yeah when they flip me
off they start arguing back and they
know it's their fault yeah but if they
go here it completely disarms me and I
go my bad yeah what are you gonna argue
with yeah exactly oh my God that guy's
great isn't it I feel the worst when
someone is like super slow and I'm like
what the [__] and then it's like a
really old person but they shouldn't be
[__] they shouldn't be [__]
driving though no no you're the ones
that drive into like farmers markets and
stuff they're like this yeah they drive
like this
but honestly though the way they drive
is like some old people they're not
looking anywhere they're the only ones
on the road and like when you're driving
and you're trying to be a defensive
driver you have to be very you have to
account for everybody that's like in
front of you and like near your vicinity
so like when an old person's driving
like that it's it's a wild card it's
dangerous every time I've almost died
from someone swerving into me it's some
old lady on a bucket
[__] in the car she has no business
driving but of course they all Drive
armories for some reason they're having
like a [__] Lincoln and from the 90s
so it's all made out of [__] iron
stairwell's like this [__]
good Lord dude driving a [__] half a
tank and so then I'm in my little
plastic Mini Cooper yeah trying to stay
alive out here like plastic they're all
in hot iron skillets man yeah exactly
it's [__] bananas every single time I
see a car that just Rams into a business
I feel like it's always old people
and it is yeah it's always old people
that just drive in like all the way
drive into the drive-in you know I was
driving I was going up Atlantic
I was going up Atlantic before
Huntington and you know there's a
Ralph's over there yeah we're both in
the left turning lane and there's a car
in front of me it's like a pretty old
Toyota Camry and I was in the Miata at
the time
I see this guy's reverse lights turn on
and I'm like why is he reversing in this
left turn lane that's weird because I'm
right behind him and he starts backing
up and he keeps going he keeps going and
I'm like what the [__] what the [__] I'm
laying on my horn because I'm like this
guy's gonna hit me he [__] is my car
dude and sure enough I'm like what the
[__] was this guy trying to do
so we pull over and I'm like and he's
he's the oldest man I've ever seen oh
he's the oldest man he was a sweet sweet
brown man yeah and I looked at his
license plate and we exchanged info and
it was like he was born like
1940 [__] six or something and I was
like dude that's pretty crazy like this
dude is very old he should probably
shouldn't be driving he's still in the
70s though dude voted for John F Kennedy
like when he was 18 years old yeah dude
that's pretty wild right but and then
but he looked like really old like he
looked extremely old
um and then I was like why did you start
backing up he goes oh I'm sorry like I
was trying to go to Vons the Ralph's
right there and I was like I'll try to
go to Vibe it has nothing to do with
that here's something that makes sense
yeah I was like I was like man you gotta
be careful like you can't be backing up
and trying to get a HoneyBaked Ham I was
like you can't just be reversing without
a left turning later I was like I was
like sir like you're gonna hurt somebody
like that's crazy and he's like I'm
sorry I'm sorry but there was no damage
and then that was it but like for that
it's like obviously you're like what the
[__] I want to be this [__] ass young
man can you follow me into the Vons and
help me reach the peas they're very high
I went in there and I [__] helped
them I carry the honey some sharp ass
like 80 year olds and then you have like
some 60 year olds that are like [__]
falling apart if you don't use it you
lose it went through in their life I
guess some of them run the country you
know
yikes about my [__] president right
now
not my president
so in Carmel Mountain in San Diego
there's a famous story of the
motorcyclist who drove into a 7-Eleven
in the 70s and that was my [__] Uncle
Mark not the bread
no way dude was he old no
no you lose control it's 20s he was on a
motorcycle yeah he did he had to ditch
out and he just ditched through the
front door of a 7-Eleven Oh I thought it
was like a rumble the Bronx situation
where he was terrorizing them he was
chasing them down
the video of somebody driving into the
fireworks store no and then all these
fireworks yeah yeah no yeah this whole
thing just blows up yeah pretty wild why
was that yeah that video uh nope have
you do you have any road rage incidences
no the way you stared off right now was
like a war veteran yeah yeah you were
like yeah no I do have one
um it's probably like two years after I
got my license and I was on the freeway
and I get cut off maybe by inches this
guy misses me yeah
um
like near death situation yeah and um
he's just driving through people
swerving off
um and this is when I was definitely
less stoic
and so I followed him
and I had a smoothie in my car tight
[__] that [__] what kind of smoothie was
it uh I don't remember but the Jamba
Juice
because the thing was I didn't chuck it
on the freeway it was like he got off
tried to escape I got off he hit the red
light off the off ramp was sitting there
um flipped me off and then I chucked it
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah and then he
gets out of the car you off like you did
something well that's that's what that's
what it is though like people like are
just entitled I don't know they think
that like you're in the wrong
um or maybe they know that they're in
the wrong they don't give a [__] and
they just want to antagonize yeah that
happens a lot
but yeah that's kind of my dream though
to throw a beverage at somebody you ever
did that but the horse is like don't
yeah yeah yeah because you look like an
[__] maybe maybe that's what stops me
don't miss lands into a trash truck I
would miss okay somebody else's car and
they swear straight up not athletic I
would miss yeah yeah okay this is this
is not really like road rage incidents
but I thought about this the other day
and you guys can't judge me but this is
like a real thought I had and it was
like I was driving through I was driving
through this park and there was two
girls just walking and I had a coffee
from Phil's and in my head I just
thought and I I think about this every
now and then I would never do it but I
think about it and I think it's really
funny but I would never ever ever do
that when I was driving and I was like
it wouldn't be funny if I just like
chucked my coffee like out the door for
no reason just add these girls like that
would be so mean and that would ruin
their day it's hot coffee no no like
iced coffee some mojito scolding hot and
then you just Chuck it out them and then
you just drive off like
that's so [__] up you wouldn't I would
never do that you'd never do it why do
you even have thoughts like that but
it's like are you okay no yeah but I
would never do it and I think about it I
laugh really hard and I just continue on
my day and I think we have to do a
little of that like we have to do that a
little bit more because we all have
thoughts like that right yeah don't we
I'm done intrusive thoughts I've done
that actual thing but with water
balloons you know I think about buying
them a cup of coffee not throwing one
dude you're like I [__] think I do we
used to do that when people got out of
Montebello High I mean we would drive by
and just throw water balloons at them
like don't just ruin their day wouldn't
it
funny like you would never need to do
yeah but then I was also that age so
it's like but I'm not like in my 20s
doing that to anybody I'm a 30 year old
okay let's just keep water balloons in
your car I keep Jolly Ranchers in my car
for this reason
dude no I would never I would never so
you don't have that thought at all is
that just me I've lived that thought
already so you got that at your system
and I know it's funny I got one I
remember this so I was I was living in
L.A and it was like you know Rush Hour
as always [__] nuts and I was in a
particular part of town I was like I
didn't know where I was going I was
going to drive into like a [__] set
thing and I was like I don't know where
the [__] I am and like the the road
Forks so it's like it feeds into another
Lane and so I was just like trying to I
was like okay I'm in the wrong lane [__]
I gotta get in this Lane and I look over
and this chick next to me I guess she's
been pissed at me the whole time but I
didn't even know I've seen it for the
first time and she's like she's looking
at me she's like I'm not letting you in
she like
whoa and I was immediately like whoa I
didn't even know that you were like mad
at me already I just got here like from
this light and then
um but immediately I was so [__]
immediately mad I was just like I hope
you [__] die
like from zero to 100 I was completely
fine like my air conditioner works I had
no reason to be that mad your reaction
just came out of nowhere I was like oh
[__] oh my God that was a full reaction
look at you like
she was just like like like she was just
still like had that mad face but it was
kind of like like out crazy like she was
kind of like did he really say that kind
of like oh wow you topped her yeah I
think so but I made her go oh [__] after
that like I spent the whole rest of the
time thinking that like oh my God damn
dude zero to 100 are you okay yeah I've
had intrusive like it's been a long time
since I've had intrusive thoughts like
that and if I did have is that what
that's called yeah like like you want to
kill him but you you don't know it's any
thought like that where like what if I
just drove off this Cliff right now or
the wheelchair you know what I mean it's
like those thoughts that just like come
in it's like what if I don't I don't
even go there because then it starts
actually being considered right so then
um road rage all that stuff
at this point when things happen I just
laugh it off I'm just like oh that's
cool that's nice that's cool and then I
move on but um the the most recent thing
where I was like holding myself back
from like actually doing anything is I
bought that little van in Hawaii right
so then um it's a it's it's like a
go-kart it's weak as [__] and one of the
scariest things was um I was at an
intersection driving through and then
these two girls like college girls in
the SUV they didn't even wait to turn
they just went for an almost [__]
crashed right into us they went straight
to us and swerved around us and I saw
the [__] look in their faces and I
was like damn dude they're gonna hurt
somebody and at that moment um when
you're in a slow car you can't go fast
you just you're just dead like you know
when you have a car that's actually a
little bit newer or better you could
swerve out I couldn't swerve I was just
stuck and I was like yeah bro I just had
to hope that they turned or else I would
have died and I was with Hannah my and
my nephews and then I was like [__] man
we could have [__] died and the
funniest thing is like so Hannah didn't
even know that we were right about to
die because she doesn't know the road
she's just in trains all day she doesn't
know driving driving on the right side
nah so she was just talking having a
conversation the whole time I'm all like
[__] and my nephews are behind me and
they saw that [__] they're like oh [__]
like they look like they saw a ghost
Hannah's still going off having a
conversation with us and we're just like
and in my head I'm like should I turn
around and I gotta lecture these drunk
ass [__] they're gonna kill somebody
maybe I should kill them before they
kill somebody oh that's good and then
that's what I'm thinking like crazy
right and I'm like that was scary like I
almost died right there yeah
and I'm like what if they're down the
street right now they hit somebody
that's walking across the street and
that's that's all I could start thinking
about it's just like I don't know if she
was talking about YouTube or some video
she saw she just kept going and the
whole car was silent and she had no idea
and I pulled up and I was like you know
we almost just died right now she goes
really
what happened were you such a good
driver you swerved away from that I
thought it was over and
yeah damn your chick thinks you're a
good driver that's big
because they trust you that's big yeah
does hey does Nikki get mad at you like
have you been in the car with her when
she like when you have a road rage
incident does she get mad at you yes oh
dude I told you guys well this wasn't a
road rage isn't exactly not yet anyway
but like I was oh God I was outside this
this like tuber party one time like
downtown L.A and it was like late at
night it was like we got there at 10 30
or some [__] and we show up and there's
these two drunk guys there's [__]
yelling and yelling and yelling and I
feel Nikki like
we do that thing to me like where it's
like squeezing me extra tight like
letting me know she's a little bit
scared and that just pissed me off
because these guys are just being
[__] and I was like hey yo why don't
you guys shut the [__] up and then if
you see me like why did you do that you
made me even more scared yeah yeah yeah
because then the guys were like oh what
do you want to do blah blah blah and I'm
like dude these guys are so drunk I'm
not worried about them or whatever but
then I didn't know that Nikki felt like
like she's like well at that point you
don't know what the [__] could happen
they could actually just come at you and
come at me or whatever so that I learned
a lesson from that though where it's
like I thought that I was like doing the
right thing sticking out for her but I
found out I was making her feel even
more comfortable but still lose lose
yeah is it like um you felt like she
felt like you're bringing on the
attention now yeah exactly whereas I was
just trying to shame them into shutting
the [__] up which never worked because
they were just being belligerent but
yeah he does that like if there was a
situation where like he you know he
thinks he's being and he was standing up
I'm like sometimes it's better to just
leave it alone though like when are the
people like you're right
like tail between their legs okay it's
like it usually causes we're gonna we're
gonna beat them all up
road rage is probably the best example
of that because most situations are
exitable like you just not deal with it
yeah yeah I think I learned that with
with my my dad like growing up had the
worst road rage it was so like I hated
seeing it as a kid yeah so then I think
that's why now I'm very like I just
don't care which [__] happens on the
road but he was like he like I never
knew if he was gonna get in a fight on
the way to school and then one day he
was taking me home from school and I was
like I think I was I was nine or ten and
then uh when someone cuts my dad off at
the time he's chill now but when someone
cuts him off he goes in front of them
and break checks them and does all this
[__] like it's like that's too much it's
like a circus act and then one time a
dude uh pulled over then of course my
Dad pulled over too and then that guy is
that's Pete yeah no that guy came out of
his car and was like what the like I got
my kid in the car you're doing all this
[__] oh [__] started yelling my dad
my dad rolls
and a guy like stuck in the thing and
then my dad saw his face dude he fell
for that trick yeah and then the guy was
trying to grab my dad and my dad closed
the window and he was like and he
started driving off
and the guy's arm is in the window but
of course I'm crying because I'm dirty
dude holy that's a coward bro in theory
it's like gangster he's fighting look
come closer
it's like a theory that's like cool but
like when if that's your dad and you're
a kid it's like that's not I hated
seeing that and then that night we like
uh my dad was like hey uh don't fight no
he he wanted to pray together
he was a no
Jesus thank you for letting me win the
fight with the guy's other arms that's a
good shot yeah exactly what Pacquiao
would say I believe he fell for it thank
you
the best technique I could at the end of
the fight I buried Jesus I buried his
arm in the yard thank you God bless you
amen thank you for blessing me with the
best boxing skills ever he was like he
wanted to pray about like because I
think he was super that was his limit
and then he he was like bad let's pray
together and then that I'll never do
this again and then he never did it
again oh man I wish you would she was
praying about you know how he won
another fight and he's got he's badass
yeah he stopped doing it and I think by
that time but but when I started driving
I was doing the same [__] and then I
stopped was the other guy like when you
said um my kids in the car what's your
dad like so is mine no he didn't say you
should my dad was going like this all
the time what he was planning what it's
like a [__] thing to get them to like
get close yeah yeah I'm gonna try that
it's funny one thing that I changed my
whole [__] on on like road rage is I was
in the car with my mom and then like I
think some guy cut me off what I was
getting pissed and I was like you see
these dumb ass drivers I don't believe
people drive like this like I'm younger
and I still drive better than them and
then she goes she was like you're only
mad because you suck at driving
oh and I was like
that really stuck me like oh [__] dude
because if I was better I would see 10
steps ahead yeah yeah it's like and then
you would see the idiot coming down you
would see and then I just I was just
like damn like you're right and she goes
if you're So you you're so good you'd be
so confident you can maneuver you could
do all this stuff and then um you
wouldn't you wouldn't be caught off
guard
yeah it's like you're you're mad because
you're caught off guard kind of true you
know and I'm like damn you're right I
just got to be a sick driver yeah that's
kind of why like I hate when people honk
their horn but it's not because you're
in the wrong or something they just honk
it because they got startled and then
they're mad that you scared them other
people just overuse the horn yeah
like the light just turned green but
dude people are on their phones now and
I I need the horn yeah I need it yeah
everyone's on their [__] phone now so
I gotta be like yo wake up get up get
back on the road please people going
ridiculously slow when it's already like
traffic like oh my it's already fast
traffic and they're kind of breaking and
they're [__] it up because they're on
their phone and they're like oh [__] and
then they they continue to go but it's
like a lot of times too it's like I feel
you I could always tell when someone's
about to cut me off yeah like I could
[__] see it sure yeah you start to
yeah you can kind of see and you're like
oh this [__] doesn't even know
I'm here this dude doesn't even know I'm
like because and also too you have to be
mindful of like where you are in
relation to the person next to as far as
like you want to drive in someone's
blind spot no yeah exactly like it's
like little things like that that
feedback to happen right yeah a lot of
people don't think that way so then when
they start trying to merge they don't
even look over their shoulder sometimes
and then boom there you are in their
[__] blind spot you ever fought over
a parking spot
no I've gotten closer a couple times
people have died over parking spots
that's the dumbest thing but by the time
they're done arguing you could have been
in your another spot in the store out
and home right
yeah that's why yeah but they
disrespected me yeah and you gotta you
gotta tell them and they're physically
standing in the spot you're the best
sit way out of all of this but be so
rich that you don't have to integrate
with the pores yeah okay you don't go
shopping no fighting in the parking lot
helicopter helicopter no traffic yeah
but you know what I read about this so
when the owner of the Indianapolis Colts
he has a helicopter and all the
neighbors [__] about how he's flying
overhead all the stuff late at night and
stuff like that yeah it's too loud city
ordinances about when he can fly his
helicopter he's a billionaire what kind
of lifestyle is that as a billionaire
it's just another tier of problems no
matter how much money you have always
more because we have billionaire
neighbors that are complaining no he's
got the commoners [__] writing
letters of the city and [__] why because
he has to go over their houses yeah
exactly well he's not that rich then
because billionaires they live on an
island
yeah their problems are probably crazy I
think I'll stick with my assassinations
I'll stick with my road rage problems
that's true I deal with roll rage before
assassination yeah
[Music]
foreign